I'm with a Taliban guy who says to me
look you don't want to do this too often
we took a vote before you came down
on whether to kill you
kidnap you'll do the interview he said
you're lucky this time the vote went
your way but you'll never know which way
we've wrote until you come here
[Music]
so Sean obviously we've met you before
thanks so much for coming in again but
for anyone that's watching or listening
for the first time could you just
briefly introduce who you are and what
you're known for
um Sean Langan I'm a documentary
filmmaker and journalist uh
specializing in foreign war
correspondent films
um and I kind of spent 10 years doing
all the wars in Iraq Afghanistan
um that's kind of
specifically I guess what I'm uh I mean
I would hate to say what I'm known for
it's not like an achievement on my CV uh
but last time I was here uh speaking
about the time I was kidnapped by the
Taliban but uh it's a bit like saying
you know getting run over by bus is an
achievement but okay I understand that
um okay so we're gonna go back to the
start and could you just tell us a
little bit about your childhood and your
early career a kind of a potted history
of how you became a journalist
um
I mean I grew up in London North London
uh and I kind of fell into journalism
uh
I was sort of like most people I think I
didn't really have a a vocational
Direction I sort of just doing lots of
things but I I sort of was the the lucky
first break I had was coming of age in
the late 80s just around the Rave period
where Fleet Street newspapers suddenly
had style art they wanted to write about
style fashion clubs and you know if they
couldn't hire six-year-old journalists
so there was this break for young kids
coming out so I think my first
cakes in journalism
and I'm laughing because I don't know
why I gave it up I was like Club
correspondent or Rave correspondent so I
would uh go to Ibiza Barca writing about
clubs for magazines like GQ and a squire
and you know I was paid to go raving and
I could expense whatever young people
do at those clubs I I guess a lot of
them didn't have receipts on those
expenses they didn't care and you know I
and I was allowed to come into work late
that's kind of what I was doing but and
I remember getting but there was a
downside it's a first world problem this
that I found it interesting DJs quite
mind-numbing talking about beats per
minute and I remember sitting there
interviewing I think it was a weirdo on
DJ called Pete Tong I'm like it's got to
be more to life
and so I literally went off to Berlin
Wall was falling and I funded my own
trip and I went to the Soviet Union just
as it was collapsing so that's I
literally segued from Rave interesting
DJs to foreign correspondent
because but how old were you then it's
about 28 29 right okay so do you think
you would just get into a point in your
life where like you say there's more to
life than this but you were like I this
isn't going to be the next 10 years 20
years of my career I didn't really have
a plan I just had enough of anything DJs
to talk about but you know and it was
lovely I mean it's lovely uh what's not
to like going to to but it was really
luck
uh and I always say this is for my kids
and afraid that you you you most of us
don't know what you want to do in life
and so I was writing magazines and where
my TV career started was uh
I was doing an article freelance
journalist went to cashmere for I think
a magazine like GQ a squad there was a
family British family whose kids have
been kidnapped
so I was writing a like a story about
this family and it was before 9 11 no
one had heard of
uh Islamic extremists or Terror and uh
the BBC had a series called video
diaries where they gave memes the public
a camera and to film their lives and
they would never give it to journalists
because they didn't want professionals
and this is the kind of sign of how
unprofessional was they went they gave
they weren't well you're such a you're
not a trained news journalist you
clearly spent going to clubs and things
but why didn't you have this camera
because I hadn't had any news training
when I was in Kashmir filming this video
dive for the BBC about me as a
journalist with the families whose kids
have been kidnapped and then I went to
try and meet the kidnappers
uh I didn't know how to tell a news
story so I would be interested in what I
was eating and what the local population
you know could have a girlfriend
boyfriend
and so I just filled my life without
knowing how to do it like John Simpson
news reporter and it was the BBC looked
and went God this is you're doing a new
story in a non-news way so
that that was the start of my TV career
so I was I ended up doing foreign
kind of news these stories but in a non
non-newsy way it almost sounds like the
like vlogging in a way I I mean yeah I
was what he said well I was an
instagrammer yeah you were influencer
early influence no but I wasn't paid
products saying it's a great Hotel
flight believe me no no uh yeah it was
it was video diaries I was very naive I
got uh I got ambushed by I was looking
for these young Backpackers in a village
in the mountains in there it's beautiful
it looks like Switzerland would have
done hundreds of years ago
and I was going to meet one of the
kidnappers and out of the woods to come
all these mudged in and I'm filming my
video don't no one's trained me how to
do it so I I'm like this
uh idiot savant and I'm looking at the
camera going all coming up behind me
like it's a pantomime and I just count
on filming
so this whole thing's on camera
and this is my first ever documentary
and it's like a kind of what not to do
in a war zone and so they're all coming
out shouting and screaming
and I have this lovely translator and it
was only six months later I knew what
they were saying in the edit Suite we
were so you this is how naive I was you
you hear these and ones that Afghan one
was a couple of Arabs pointing guns and
they're shouting pointing at me and my
fixer it's got a very calm voice but
when I got it translated it's
uh you hear me saying is there a problem
anything I can do to help and my fix is
saying no don't worry but what we
realized six months when I'm editing
what they're saying translating one of
them saying we told you not to bring any
foreigners I don't know if I could swear
but you know we'd warned you we'd
[ __ ] kill the foreigners here then
you hear me saying is there any uh is
there a problem and my fix has sets me
English no no it's fine and then the
other one says right we're going to cut
his [ __ ] head off
and I say is there anything I can do to
help
so in fact I look back at that and think
thank God I didn't know what's going on
and that kind of Innocence naivety
was quite useful at that but that was
the beginning but that I mean what
occurs to me is if if that had been me
yeah that would have been the end of my
I would have watched that in the edit
suite and thought well that was a lucky
Escape I'm gonna go back to DJs and
interviewing people in of ether I'm
going to go back to Peter I'm going to
go back to Pete Tong yeah
um what was that wasn't the case for you
so did it was it that you thought you'd
really achieved something or did you
find it quite exciting or how you know
what what what because it's not even
like you say you weren't a trained
journalist who were like well these are
the risks of the job you were someone
that kind of blundered into it had a
pretty slow situation yeah did that not
scare you off no so I think when you
know so when I tell these stories I'm
not
that that's the bit you tell you know
like that oh I nearly
whacked
and actually at the end when they they
all calm down
uh they all said these Muslim you know
who you're doing this for I said BBC and
then we love the BBC they're all like
shooting in the air oh God so it all
ended well and I think that kind of
naivety they could pick up on that I was
not a threat But to answer the question
what really it wasn't those Thrills and
the you know people think you've me and
my friends who do this kind of thing
you've got death wishes or
uh Adrenaline Junkies
and that's a small part of it because
I've been struggling as a freelance
journalist not sure I want to do I woke
up my morning in Kashmir
love was was consciously happy like not
like I wish one day I will be or if I
had this I were going I'm I'm happy and
it's because I'd found something I loved
doing
a storytelling a vocation it's a
difference in a vocation and a career
something I loved
and you're in this fascinating
a new environment and for me uh on a
kind of more seriously what's Driven me
is that the the there was this polish
foreign correspondent who said you know
the real journalism is trying to
understand the other side the other
point of views so being paid I wasn't
paid much money but to be paid to go off
to to hear other people's stories other
parts of the world was just a dream come
true
and but for some reason yeah I did tend
to end up rather a lot of these close
calls I think my nickname at Channel 4
was dead man walking wow yeah
um must have felt good when you go in
the situations
about that nickname I didn't know but
yeah uh so it didn't start off that
wasn't my initial drive and I was you
know I was 20 something and it was quite
a thing it was quite I think it's
because I didn't realize until you
really suffer you're not it's a bit of a
game
but that it it at the beginning that
wasn't my main motivation
okay and was there an element of you
know you know presumably when people
watched that video they were going
wow oh my God like you know was there a
bit of like yeah I did that you know was
there a bit of bravado there that you
could put yourself in these situations
well that's that's well so when I look
so funny like that documentary was 10
years before I was kidnapped and when I
was kidnapped and the irony has been I I
woke up on my in my cell one day when I
was kidnapped thinking wow I haven't
literally in terms of Miles cashmere is
then uh it's next to Afghanistan the
tribal I was literally miles from where
I'd started my journey 10 years before
as a filmmaker and I thought I would
travel that far my first story is about
five Backpackers who kidnapped
10 years later I'm in a Cell myself so
you come back to be beheaded
and I realized I would be like Icarus
that Greek myth of the the young man
flying ever closer to the Sun and being
worn by his father because you know they
had these wings
made of feathers that if you fly to too
close to that sun you're gonna
burn out but he was drawn to that and I
kind of was aware that as time went on
as you say you know I'd come back and it
was literally people like oh my God this
is like Sean's been attacked by a marble
he's about it looks I look in a lot of
the documentaries I was just avoiding
being killed
and laughing
and I think maybe there was this thing
where subconsciously I'd hate to admit
it that I was forever upping the stakes
uh I won't blame anyone around me but
there was the the people commissioning
me it was part of that if you're going
to watch a Sean Langan documentary you
know if there's going to be some close
calls so one has to be careful but there
it's it's you're living the life
tripping the light fantastic you're
doing good work so I I don't regret
anything that ever happened to me and
I've and
that's easy for me to say I've lost
about eight friends blown up or some
committed suicide it's it's uh as a
result of the job they were doing 100
yeah PTSD or something like that yeah
I'm most killed doing the job I think
one of eight or nine of my friends have
been killed because that what I was
going to ask was you know when you're a
young single guy trying to prove himself
going out to these things sort of get
that but when you mentioned about the
the hurt it causes of the people did it
sort of change when your children were
born did that sort of make you want to
not put yourself into these situations
or was it still something that was
uh well to my uh fighting bats and no I
think that was actually when I was doing
some of the most dangerous stuff right
well and and was it just that do you
think at that point
I'm just trying to get inside your head
a little bit with it really was it
something that didn't really occur to
you did you not feel the sort of mortal
danger no yeah
well I look at my sons now you know or I
like anyone when you're in their 20s you
know you're going off in a year abroad
yeah correct
near miss his car accident so and I
think
we it's I mean it's different when a
young person
because you're not so my I don't have
that excuse I'm I was supposed to be
supposedly a responsible Adder but I
think it's very difficult to envisage to
to Really envisage your own death and I
remember uh
uh it's it's it it's almost impossible
especially for a Westerner where we're
not living amongst that that fear of and
the risk of being shot every day
but I do remember obviously with some a
British unit in Afghanistan
and when they were cut out there was
about 19 20 of them and they were
surrounded by 500 Taliban and it was so
intense
and and I remember that that's I
understood that meaning of bite the dirt
whatever it is because I was literally
trying to get
get further in an inch or two into the
ground because the bullets were so
intense flying around and at that point
I remember like what the [ __ ] am I doing
here
and because it was so intense and closed
it was my first time in my life I was
able to really like wow death is just an
inch away God and I felt horrible yeah
and nothing felt worth it because I'm
like I'm in a in a ditch and Helmand and
I at that point my children would have
been
uh
three and two and it's just occurred as
I'm telling the story
to my shame even though at that point I
thought I was going to die in about a
minute later an RPG air burst these
things which are designed to blow up in
the end they shower down shrapnel
this we heard it explodes and it
showered and it was like standing under
a shower because you hear this and I
look at this pretty Soldier and we just
think we've got to be dead and we look
around and somehow this shrapnel some
miracle lands all around us without
because a little bit of shrapnel will
just cut
so that was that time now as I was
making a film called Feist however these
British soldiers but
that was before I went off and got
kidnapped so to my shame even though
that's when death became a very a
reality and the consequences and the
suffering would have caused my loved
ones
but I forgot
that moment I think well okay I mean
that seems like a perfect point to get
into that story right
um how did it start how did that um
project start well this this was picking
up on your thread that you know
the each stock I think you know the
first documentary I did was a completely
legitimate reason for journalism was a
good story happened to be involved and I
was abducted briefly or ambushed by
these Islamic uh budgeting so then you
next stage well why didn't you do the
Taliban in Afghanistan and then wow
that's like pretty hairy why didn't you
go to Iraq do the war and by this point
all my documentaries are about
insurgents U.S combatants or British and
civilians so the level of violence
rather like the level of violence in the
Middle East was just ratcheting yeah
and I did this doctor two documentaries
were very you know successful
called meet time and fight about when
both of those films there was a lot of
fighting and near-deathy moments me and
that was the one where I'm with the
Taliban guy who says to me look you
don't want to do this too often uh we
took a vote before you came down
on whether to kill you
uh kidnap you'll do the interview he
said you're lucky this time the vote
went your way but you'll never know
which way we've voted until you come
here my God so I knew that and that was
a film called Finance had a meeting
today man and yet the year later
that was when it was like okay well that
was a big six that went down really well
that documentary where I'd been warned
don't do this and I ignored that warning
like Icarus going flying to the close of
the Sun so the next documentary this
when I got kidnapped and I'll give you
the TV proposal sure but it was more
like a [ __ ] suicide letter so in this
proposal it's my proposal I'm
responsible so the idea was
you know I did a few films in
Afghanistan but everyone in Afghanistan
soldiers everyone knew that the it was
across the board in the tribe areas of
Pakistan that's where there was the
training camps Al-Qaeda training camp
secret training elsewhere uh Osama Bin
Laden was thought to be
so in a way no one had been there but
all roads lead to where that's where you
wanted to go so my
proposal was the broadcaster went good
idea was to cross from Afghanistan which
is pretty much the most dangerous place
but I managed to find a more dangerous
place to cross into the tribal as when
no foreigners allowed
so they're not even allowed there no
it's literally signpost saying no
foreigners Beyond this point so why
would you do that I used to laugh and
that doesn't mean Osama you know
wow and then
I was I mean every time I asked that
question I'll go red with embarrassment
before I answered that uh also Pakistan
had denied the world there's any
terrorist training camps
so they would
uh uh
I mean
well I'm sure they Pakistan themselves
wouldn't but you'd get killed for being
there for for showing that Pakistan
wasn't quite telling the truth when it
says there are no terrorist training
camps right so the idea was to be the
first person into these Anita spent
months negotiating with the Taliban to
make a documentary about their secret
training campus why would they do that
why would they agree to let you do that
you're going to keep asking these
questions it may be like an idiot
turns out they wouldn't do that right
okay what what's the benefit to them to
having a BBC documentary
yeah so so well
it's the same now you know I'm uh
wherever you go in the world
uh
everyone wants to be understood and
actually we're we're less aware of the
rest of the world
being one of those major capitals and
cultural centers but the whole world you
go to any Village anywhere in the world
they'll know about English football
players or the Premier League they'll
know about TV or you know the Taliban
love Mr Bean videos
I mean I've been seeing in a village and
they'd be showing me a video of a
beheading and the next thing is Mr Bean
wow I remember being I think they were
trying to talk to me show me videos and
then Mr Bean came up and I'm like and
you're like oh sorry and they love Mr
Bean so they know all about us
and actually wherever people in the
world there is this they they they they
they
there's a I sent this sort of pain that
why don't you like oh what what's wrong
with her and they want us to to to to
respect to like them to understand them
uh
so so there's a and there's a genuine
desire on that part to be understood
that's why when you and they love the
BBC I mean we can mention the BBC they
uh which I why I think it's I don't mean
to be political
tragedy if the BBC's getting cut all the
time because wherever you go in the
world people listen to the World Service
in the local language from the town so
it's an amazing resource so when you
turn up saying on BBC they're like we
want to we want to speak right
less so to other channels but so
and I that was part of my stick I would
say some it's in your interest uh this
is my stick with I'm using that but my
way in with uh Islamic uncertainties
like you're fighting Jihad holy war
and you're using a weapon but the word
is part of your so that's what I said
now actually when I got kidnapped to do
those training camps I generally believe
what happened was some of the Commanders
thought it was a good I said it's in
your interest I mean it's not really an
interest all about sequel trainers but I
was saying it is
and some thought it was
and the guys who I negotiated with
genuinely thought this is good good for
us good for the movement
to a few other people out of the
wednesbury that is not a good idea
and someone in Pakistan might have
thought that's not a good idea I don't
know but so when I went there
there was obviously summer said let's
kidnap him I guess it's maybe the vote
again you know the vote 100 against me
so let's so you arrive in the area where
you're going to do the crossing yeah at
what point did you realize something was
off so the weirdest thing is most
abductions begin with the classic
abduction is being a hood over your head
bundled in the back of a car gun in the
face fear
and actually my the beginning of my
kidnap started like every one of my
other in my documentation I went to meet
Taliban which so when I used to when you
talk about I didn't I never enjoyed the
whole process of meeting insurgents in
Iraq
Afghanistan because it's it's also
inducing because they they're under huge
risk they think you're going to set them
up right or you're being tail by CIA or
Special Forces so they they're nervous
when you they get you to meet them in
the middle of nowhere
and you're waiting in a really dangerous
era and in Iraq and build up hairs I I
remember just sitting there with other
people who would want to kidnap me or
kill me and I'm trying to meet somebody
doesn't turn up so it's incredibly
stressful and I had often when I'm
meeting and interviewing people being
blindfolded put in the back of the car
taking to secure area to film
so this time when uh the car meets me on
the side of the road near pashar in
Pakistan
there's a Muller young guy it felt like
it felt great I'm great I finally met
these Taliban contacts they're going to
take me to where I needed the interview
and they said look just keep down in the
back of the car with the shore when we
go through checkpoints
so it was feeling like good news
uh smoother than usual if anything well
yeah it is going well uh there were some
bad signs on the way up when uh the
young guy didn't have a beard he had
like prod a gun belt
and you know the Glock gun and and I was
thinking he's not right this guy
and the Muller who I later called Muller
medicated
these are some warning signs but you're
now in this car going to the tribes he
had like all these medicines in his bag
and any pink yellow blue pills and he
said I take these for my headache and I
look at them one says because it's all
like little bits of the paper
prescription or one said for severe
psychotic disorder oh my God all right
you're taking these he goes headache
come on that's a bad headache so the two
men I'm in a car with Muller medicated
and a young Gucci Taliban with his
I I so I had a bat so just just for
every anyone that it's kind of like
regular parlance but for anyone who
isn't sure what is a Muller a Muller is
a it's a religious it's a priest the
equivalent of in Islam so it'd be a
senior member of that you well you can
be a village
but it would be traditionally someone
who is went to a madrasa religious
school called a madrasa has had some
learning and is now a local and there'll
be different levels but it's supposed to
be a learned religious man right this
guy I don't think could barely read I I
I'm being serious he probably couldn't
read the Quran in Arab they learned by
wrote yeah okay and he was so off his
eyes were rolling so I I uh but so I
called him Muller medicated
uh Hilo so when we but anyway you meet
sort of colorful characters like that
sure I get in with
uh and it still felt good and we drove
into the mountains
it's like a a day's drive and then we
and I remember I don't know if I told
this last time but then
you know I then was
this young Gucci guy and then this other
man joined us with an AK-47
and they asked if they could blindfold
me so this was my first and then as I'm
being blindfolded I suddenly think oh my
God this is you know bearing in mind
that Taliban Commander's warning in my
previous trip where you you know we
there was a vote whether to kill you
kidnap you or let you do the interview I
was like oh God maybe the votes to kill
me because I'm now being blindfolded
because I was looking over at precipice
and were they been fairly cordial still
yeah very cordial do you mind if we
blindfold you and I would say there's
not much you can say that to that it's
like actually and I did about it so but
it was where I knew I was kidnapped was
so I went I was sent into a house
uh
uh put into this guest house oh sorry
guest room which they boarded up and I
think it had previous
uh occupant was goats because it stank
of like goats tiny thing I was on my own
and this is we're just gonna keep here
to to make sure you're right no one has
followed you we don't want the CIA or
America British whoever
for six and then you can film in a
couple of days we're going to let you
into your Al-Qaeda whoever you want so
for the first two days I'm sitting here
thinking I was already kidnapped
thinking this is going well
for the two full days
I mean I had some feeling that Muller
medicated and uh Gucci kid with his
Glock
but but uh and were you on your own or
were you I was on my own because there's
no fixer here he was traveling
separately for our own security they
said well I I well I it was to honestly
I'd been filming with Taliban where
or Iraq insurgents where you're
surrounded by guys with guns and waving
knives and it went well so it seems
ridiculous that I am saying this is felt
go well but it was no different to my
other experiences where suddenly then
you're out you've got 50 guys I mean the
time in Iraq in Afghanistan when the
command had won me you don't want to do
this too often I'd plan to meet four or
five Taliban
and it was about five minutes from the
main British base and 60 Taliban just
roll in and RPGs
uh and I'm just like right you know it's
like [ __ ] you know and are they feeding
you and giving you water and all that
sort of thing bro
yeah no in the in the world so this
thing yeah they may uh I never forget
the commander who uh was both Charming
he had to charm of the devil because
he'd be very charming and then later on
in my captivity when teeth were falling
out he'd be like whatever
he said on the first night uh what would
you like for breakfast I went fried egg
the next morning they bought me a fried
egg and like you see like how good the
service is
um wow I I knew there was a Dawning
feeling
a sort of slow uh creepy feeling Over
the Horizon that I was trying to keep at
Bay that this was uh not right and to be
honest with you
sorry so much before I even left London
I was saying my goodbyes because there
was a feeling this time wasn't right and
you you do develop a sixth sense
but I I'd ignored that
great and it's a very strong feeling
that I wasn't going to come back alive
for
something was going to go wrong
seriously wrong and I kind of put that
out the back of my head thinking but and
I look back and I regret not listening
to that I had a bad feeling before I
left London
I wake up at seven in the morning in my
bed it was like watching a theater take
place in front of you he shout the
commanders shouting at the Muller who
brought me who's my main contact
and what I discovered later was he was
questioning him you maybe you're
involved with these forums how come they
contact you because they they don't
trust anyone and and like any Insurgent
fight there's spies within there so
they're forever killing their own a
restaurant just in case they're working
with your marriage so in front of me the
Commanders
threatening the Muller
who then gets two men come in and put a
hood over his head
and he's crying and they drag him out
and his literally just happening really
there's a door and I'm still in lying up
and sitting up in bed having watched
this
sort of silent movie no understanding
what's going on because it's obvious and
then he's outside the room and I can
hear the the guards hitting him and the
slack of an AK hitting his face and the
command is looking at me the whole time
just smiling
smiling yeah it's got this smile and
then and it feel and then the bodies I
can hear the body being dragged off and
you're waiting for the shop he didn't
hear and he just says
don't worry about it uh we arrest and
kill our own all the time it's no big
deal
he said and now we're going to check on
YouTube he's talking to me and my face
said then don't worry about it it won't
be like that case Adriana admire is the
man I told you about who I'd climbed
down the mountains he'd been killed by
the Taliban when he was doing another
story and that was embarrassing for the
Taliban because they killed him but they
let the Italian foreign journalists live
he says it's not gonna be like that like
that case that was embarrassing for us
you'll either both die you'll both live
and he walks out the room and I turn to
my fix and laugh because that's good
news you know uh and that that's when it
you know globster off we were kidnapped
and I mean
so when he was doing that and he was
smiling at you yeah do you think that
was intimidation or do you think there
was just something missing that's what I
decided to think is this is a slight
uh maybe a sociopath or he just was
looking at me as a man's getting like
we're all listening to someone being
beaten with a rifle bucks outside
well there was a lot going on I think I
mean and the other man I mean I I didn't
have that much I mean it's horrible it's
horrific hearing the noiver that that
Mueller medicated the night before was
sleeping in my room he I woke up and he
was on my bed with a knife up my throat
and uh and I literally woke up we said
don't worry
it's it was holding a knife it's like
it's not for you I just wanted to show
you he was completely he was on
psychotic medicines antisago he said I
just wanted to show you the knife I cut
the throat of Americans with
and he jumps back on the floor and he's
got that kind of sweat as someone is on
and he's explaining why my translator
how he'd killed this American slit his
throat
and then he says
and he he read the name of the guy's
patch he said to me do you know him it's
like like he's assumed we all know it
yeah and I felt physically I'm sorry
this is rather dark when I thought
and I'm like wow this guy that's one of
the uh he was one of the other people
you meet you think you are yeah because
I mean he was
you know he's not he's not properly
religious he he was like a kind
medication yeah sure and I'm sure he
wasn't a fighter I'm sure anyway so he
was one they arrested and did you see
him again or not well here's the thing
so so it's such a comp when a kidnapped
they were worried about uh because he
lived in Afghanistan they're prob I did
see him later so I thought they dragged
him off to be shot I met him just when I
was released so I was never sure if it
was a play actor confused me so I
wouldn't if I was being debriefed by
British police after I wouldn't say oh
well he's the man who brought us because
I you know I I and I didn't want me to
see him I just happened to see him in
the compound as I was leaving
says you're in a dark world when you're
kidnapped and you know there are Spooks
and various International organizations
are listening in and you never know
who's the good guys who the bad guys
okay I mean it sounds like the bad guy
is the man at 2AM with the knife to your
throat he's not a good guy no he doesn't
sound like a good guy
um okay so the the pennies drop so to
speak was your fixer native yeah yeah so
how was he taking this
uh well much worse than me initially
very quickly had some you know severe
help from his bleedings internal
bleeding from you uh and he had a
breakdown
so that forced me to be even more of
like the PE instructor the strong one to
say come on keep going
i i i and he it's I he he had a right of
all time
but that's got nothing to do with me
being more uh Adept or a stronger
character or physically more or mentally
stronger it was my Western naivety
and this is why I was like shame because
I wasn't making like I didn't think I'm
better than you but
uh what it was was I didn't want to
think this is my Western ignorance Navy
that my naivety is that it must be
really difficult to take another man's
throw and cut it or shoot a man like
that being Afghan he knew how easy and
common it is and he had actually fought
in the Jihad against the Soviet Union
that the holy war they called it
he'd been a brave Warrior
and and yet he broke very quickly and at
the end of towards the end of our
captivity so what was making me strong
was just my ignorance that it's very
hard to kill another fellow human being
well his life experience was no life's
cheap and people would get shot all the
time cut heads cut off
and towards the end of our
and it got very difficult actually
because I he was my lifeline I needed
him to translate so I could bond with
people and again try and get a phone
call to you know my outside to get
rescued so I had to keep him alive it
was real
so it's this very powerful relationship
but at the end we had a candle like we
knew we were going to be released soon
and he was on his knees you know because
he's just finishing prayers and then at
the end of prayer and even pray he's
then just on his knees relaxing
and we've got Candlelight
and I'm sitting on my bed and he's
saying to me no Sean with tears in his
eyes you know I've I'm a bit ashamed
that I've I I wasn't so strong and I've
been a bit weak but this wasn't my first
time
and I'd known him for 10 years he'd
never told me the story but he said you
know this is my second time I've been
captured
first time was when he was nine years
old as a young kid Afghan fighting the
Soviets but he was too young to have a
weapon he was handing out leaflets
against the Communists the Russians and
saying you know calling Chad and he got
captured by communist Secret Service
local Afghan and KGB forces put in a
cell with three or four other kids and
they they taught like beat them so much
and used electric cattle prods he was
badly beaten tortured but never broke
never told him anything he said it was
like an adventure and when he got out
his mum didn't even recognize him
and he said but once you've been through
that you can never do it again
so so and that to me was a well just one
of many valuable lessons but so
why I coped well in there was purely
because I've had a nice life where
but you also brought up that life is
precious humans have got a goodness and
so that background of mine helped me was
that you know
so that how long were you captured for
in terms four months you're gonna have
three just under four months just in
performance yeah
so like I mean that must have felt I
imagine like a lifetime yeah yeah so
talk us through every minute or a second
can feel like a lifetime sure see you
you realize that you're captured and
then starting the next day what's your
kind of daily life
yeah
you go you go through so you know
earlier you ask how do you do things
when you're clearly taking risks
and I was saying it's hot it's uh it's
hard to really truly envisage and your
own death
and one thing I was remarked about this
experience was it was the first time in
my life apart from one or two instances
where a bullet had just missed my head
but that that's a kind of momentary
realization that death could come and
then you forget it this is the first
time in my life where uh
the the awareness of the imminency of my
own death hit me and it hit me
like a a physical relationship I was
sadly when I'm realizing it was about
day three for like [ __ ] you know this is
because when they first tell you you it
doesn't sink in I knew they're telling
you you're under arrest you're kidnapped
I remember reading they had a you know a
Taliban official paper you are you're
here by under arrest and charged with
enemy government spies or something
and I'm like oh man we've been kidnapped
and you know I think so it was much more
realistic it's like no no we're dead
right you don't get it and it took a few
days but when it sunk in I literally
felt this physical
With the Wind taken around I literally
fell back on my and that was like death
he's like I'm right here I'm outside the
door and so you then live with death
and it was like having the Sword of
Damocles hanging over you because you're
aware every moment
and what happens at that point is you go
into autopilot and it's amazing and
literally I've talked to a Specialists
about this your lower part of your brain
your amyglidea the the ancient Marine
literally Swift kicks into action and
turns off your frontal the the make the
bit of the brain to make us advance
uh you know that conscious thought or
that goes they literally turn it off
because the lower part of the brain says
leave this to me you're in a car crash
you're going through a windscreen this
is what I deal with you know fear of
flight survival and I just didn't have
to think about anything I just knew
right I would have battened down
emotional hatches I've got to do
exercise I've got because you it just
all just seem natural survival instincts
and we try not to think about it too
much of did it just take over and happen
on its own it got into another bits and
yeah well one of the things that
happened
but again it's on automatic you they
talk about the drowning man syndrome and
people are drowning they see their whole
life flash before and they've been
recorded instances where people say wow
my whole life
well I I had that but it wasn't flashing
because I wasn't drowning
I I had for about four days
and you have to know you're going to die
for this happen I could see my whole
life performance like Scrooge on the
night before you know Christmas Eve
Carol with the coastal as well literally
I sat on my bed and I could pick age
five first day at infant school and I
see myself what I was wearing my teacher
who I named I managed to name I think 14
School teachers I could see the first
time at my best friend what he was
wearing and apparently that's your brain
again thinking this this body I'm
trapped in is dying it's about to die so
there's getting so many chemical
messages of adrenaline and like all the
alarm Bales are going off in your body
and the brain is like it's clearly like
I don't know what it needs so I give it
everything so there might be something
in this person's memory
from their life that will help them
survive this moment and it was amazing
because stuff I'd thought had forgotten
so I'd read a book you know about an sas
guy captured Behind Enemy Lines his
survival techniques a movie I'd seen
about you know just keep going
everything I picked up fragments in my
life which I thought I'd forgotten
suddenly were like oh yeah well I'll use
that you know I'd seen that in a movie
or read a book and
the other thing that kept me going
with this Total Recall of my life
was uh I just you don't want to think
about the the fact that you could have
your head cut off and you don't want to
think about the suffering your kids so
you you control emotions but I escaped
every day from my dark soul and that
experience into uh conscious daydreaming
so I would uh uh sit on my bed and say
right you know I'm gonna
uh and I can remember every school
holiday summer holiday that a daily and
your childhood summer holidays and I was
lucky enough to had a nice childhood
some holidays
or you know Sunshine sea my mother's
Portuguese so I you know we went we're
lucky enough for a talk of that became
my safe space and I would uh sit there
and there was a tiny hole at the back of
the dark cell
is about that big and if I look through
I could see a apricot tree and just be
on that with their fields and the
mountains and I would look and uh hear
the bird song so it was quite an intense
spiritual
uh thing but that's all
automatic I didn't know about that and
it really is powerful and it's so
powerful
uh and I'm not I don't want to you know
I'm a cynical old hack but uh there was
this you're so in tune with your loved
ones and and life and how wonderful life
is and you're and you're also painfully
acutely sense of how fragile it's
literally there was a spider's web
outside the hole and I would see it in
the rain and a raindrop and I'm like my
life is you know hanging on the thread
so while all this is happening all the
stuff that you're thinking about the
time you're spending in your head
basically yeah what's your contact like
with your captors like what are they
telling you are they telling you you're
going to be executed or are they saying
we're just going to hold you for a while
what's that like no so the the actual
house I was in is the Taliban safe house
was owned by a family you know like six
brothers you don't meet their wives you
know they're in kept away so but it's a
family compound and they were like
friends with the Taliban working with
them probably
strongs or you know guys and the Taliban
would come and go they had bases in the
mountains so my interaction with the
Taliban would be they would come in
very Charming Commander but you know it
was
this is The Smiling guy smiling who I
know would just
turn on the dime but my main interaction
was with the fan of the household the
pro Taliban
um past June warrior class
but the interaction as you know I told
him that last time I was here the when
they were asking me the Taliban Charming
Commander asked me the names of my
children I refused to give it to them
him and then he threatens to shoot me
and
and I said I'm sorry I can't give you
that my children's name
and then he threats to call the fixer my
fixer so I say look all right my son's
name is Gabriel
which is the one of the holiest names in
Islam the Archangel Gabriel who brought
down the Quran the Holy Quran to the
prophet after that
the the the my right all the family just
they transformed how they saw me because
the Taliban had said look these are
spies they're unbelievers because the
Taliban don't like admitting we kidnap
Jonas it kind of doesn't look good and
for money
the families their new uh that was just
rubbish and and so we developed a very
strong labor and I taught the children
English
the women
I found with this amazing invisible
support unit they'd be singing outside
my room to live my spirits but they they
heard they never saw me I never saw them
but they were great comfort
and support so I was suffering from
malnutrition and my teeth were falling
out because it's funny without sunlight
your body just oh really yeah it's
amazing so he's falling out yeah yeah
without vitamin D yeah because we don't
think there's much sun in England but
actually still getting of course
sunlight through the clouds so if you're
on a dark cell for three months
under that kind of stress and the food
wasn't great because they're in the
mountains there was a lack of fresh
vegetables fruit a lot of stringy
Chicken in those Prescott I I lost about
two or three I had dysentery as well
because that rum was full of you know it
was a room for animals
uh so I lost three stone I had dysentery
in three or four teeth fell out the
women must be hearing this so I started
going to Great Lengths like climbing
six hours walk up a mountain to get some
fresh herbs or vegetables to improve my
diet and my diet they they built up my
strength
uh so so it was this bizarre really
intense
uh relationship between me but never
what they call Stockholm syndrome you
know I never uh but it's interesting
especially not with Muller Medicaid with
that you know sure yeah but it's
interesting what I would say about um
you know they must have been
fed a load of lies about who you were
because once they started to think that
you weren't some ungodly unbeliever that
was out to punish them and poison all
the community whatever they were
actually went you know could they have
got in trouble for trying to help you
like that dude yeah 100 yeah well this
is the other thing that they this
happens where this goes back to the
original why do you want to go out to
the world to try and understand
they're off you know
the these average rural people in the
middle of nowhere
uh you would fall enough you know first
time I really lived in a passion Afghan
home I'd always been in a Guest House
Hotel going to into their lives but
never living
it's the first time in 20 years of
covering Afghanistan they opened up so
the young they're all Taliban together
but they opened up about how you know
the young boy
didn't have a beard probably hadn't
grown properly yet he got beaten by
Taliban at checkpoints he said you know
they're all just criminals the ones who
joined the Taliban and they were of
course this young boy didn't want to be
hit but he would never you'd never
criticize the Taliban to a foreign
journalist but I was no longer this
foreign journalist I was now a guest in
their home he liked Bollywood music he
fell in love with the girl and you
realize he's it's a it's it's not like
you know the news reduces people down to
headlines uh it's happening now in
Ukraine and Russia Good Guys bad guys uh
and the world's just nothing like that
so there I am within this family
uh but would you ever have lent on them
in terms of saying can you help me get
out of this well I did okay yeah and you
got well
yeah
I mean I think it's probably enough time
has passed this Taliban left a SAT phone
there
I I spent six weeks to eight weeks
trying to convince the owner of the
house
to let me phone
uh a mice but it had to step by step
slowly because you they're very they're
aware it's an incredibly dangerous
situation they could get playing
uh and it went wrong a few times but it
was like you know again I'd read enough
books and films you know you slowly
slowly to these things you know just so
I I worked over conversations got them
to like me first and then I was saying
look
because they were like when this is all
there will be good and I would say but
how my mum may not live through she
could have a heart attack and if she's
dead when I come out I don't care what
happens to me
and I wish I could call her now to say
I'm safe
so they actually got to the point where
they let me make a phone call
and it probably helped Channel 4 locate
where I was
so it did but they've got a strange
point though where well this thing they
realized when I was rescued or released
that this was a safe house for the
Taliban but not for the family who owned
it because the Taliban were living there
it is this weird thing with the owner
and me were sitting there and I wanted
to let him know that to try and get him
to let me phone Channel 4 to give me
this sat phone which I did call Channel
4 with
and I was trying to push him and then it
occurred to me [ __ ]
he's gonna he's thinking now as well
Sean
at the moment I'm in charge of Sean but
when I'm out if they all think we're
going to talk to cias that I could tell
the British secret service that's the
house I was in they would bomb because
when you're sitting there you hear the
drones hitting village houses nearby and
it was like blowing up so they're very
aware
and I suddenly realized and I'm trying
to get him I was trying to say look
you you want to help me because then
when I'm out I'll let everyone know
you're a good guy and then I suddenly
realized
he's got his children there and he's
thinking Sean going could put my fan at
risk so he might kill me even if they're
rather than me tell anyone he was
involved so it's this dance between me
and the owner of the house who we like
that we were both aware that our lives
were in each other's hands he was
protecting me from the Taliban but he
was going to rely on me to protect him
from any retaliation from The Americans
so it's a weird relationship complicated
because then you know critical works for
young people call codependent isn't it
co-dependent with that boyfriend
girlfriend well because there's a world
where his life would be a lot easier if
you had just disappeared then yeah so
you were relying on his nature to not
see that as a I was very woke and you
know what it was we were both aware he
was aware I was thinking the same thing
yeah of course I could risk and we had
this lovely understanding though
he was a lovely man he was like this
didn't say much opposite of me like
blabber out there I there's a real
understanding
of two people from others the complete
opposites of the world but this respect
understanding you know and I was
teaching his 11 year old boy that you
know
lives were at stake and he and he stood
up by the way I I had mentioned he put
his life on the line to protect me from
the Taliban because they were so taken
how I wouldn't give the names of my
children he said to the Taiwan he he
he's got the villagers resp he would he
could pull out 100 men with guns in The
Villages so the Taliban have to be
careful but he said to the Taliban uh we
have offered Sean tribal protection
you're not allowed to kill him uh in our
area which would have made it with
Tyrone couldn't then just shoot me there
they'd have to it'd be difficult for
them so he'd
done that for me because he realized
that I he he said you know we we like
what you know your good father or
whatever you know you're not who we
thought you were
so I knew he'd he'd really helped me my
life there was a lot better because him
and his wives give me good food and
protecting me and he was kind of looking
at me like but now you're a risk to me
can you tell the CIA I'm involved in
this they can put a drone strike here
but what are the Taliban doing at this
point like what because you said you
used the phone to call the broadcaster
yeah what are the Taliban donors in are
they making calls to try and get run
some money for your release was that the
purpose of your kidnap from finally it's
a society
there's various things happening to
kidnap uh there might have been various
reasons what they're doing I think
generally some commanders thought yeah
let him do an interview but then very
quickly others are like nowhere but they
weren't just interested in a kidnap
Ransom
they were like how is this journalist
got in contact one or two people away
from the leader of this group who's now
in charge of Afghanistan he's really
high up so they're thinking we need a
security who are these locals he's
meeting these contacts mother medicated
or whoever it is who's helped me if this
journalist can get to us set up meetings
or so can our enemies so part of the
reason to to capture me was to see to it
was to do internal security checks who
are these people talking to journalists
saying we'll introduce you to the leader
of the Taliban group it was the hakani
network and I'd got to people who who
could meet him directly and say yeah so
that it was security what made it very
complicated and then it was like well we
make some money you know Afghans tell
them I'm a good businessmen so any
chance to make money
well well something I have to be careful
about but I've always had the feeling
that there was this Hidden Hand in all
of this or this stop actor off stage but
I was aware of their presence like death
and that's
I was listening to the World Service
radio they gave me the route and I hear
American State Department saying the
tribal areas of Pakistan are a terrorist
Safe Haven as well Al-Qaeda train and
Pakistan's responsible
and then I hear the foreign minister of
Pakistan on the beach radio denying
there's any training camps in Pakistan
and as he's denying I can't hear his
denar because you can hear all the
training come to the mountains there's
so much testifinal weapons in the
mountains it's so loud I have to turn up
the radio to hear this guy say there
aren't there right and I was painfully
aware [ __ ]
I'm caught up this is I'm gonna sump the
dark strategic geopolitical world I'm an
embarrassment to Pakistan claiming there
are no training camps
and in fact
uh there was one point we discovered
later on when the Pakistan Secret
Service find out I've captured they're
telling the tavern what are you doing
why don't you
kidnap him in Afghanistan and there some
people were suggesting why didn't you
kill him and dump his body in
Afghanistan
so at one point the kidnap was about
money security the next bit was about
oh they're gonna kill him
kill me and put me but and then
uh I heard this was this was picked up
by British uh Signet intelligence you
know eavesdropping all I know is the the
then British foreign secretary on a
visit to Pakistan says look by the way
there's this British journalist
kidnapped and you know he's in the tribe
lyrics if he goes missing or killed and
found dead in Afghanistan we will of
course announce the world that he was in
Pakistan
and
I've heard that and all I know is that
a short time after that conversation the
Taliban I'm with a call saying don't
kill him
just uh release him quickly with some
money well it's interesting because I
mean it sounds almost more frightening
how chaotic it was like there wasn't a
clear plan of what they wanted to do
with you it was just kind of like it
sounds like it could have gone either
way at any moment and that's that's the
life hang on a thread yeah I don't know
about Cairo I didn't get that sense and
I feel quite even now saying that I
don't I'm not supposed to know about
things but it's used to pick up as a
journalist this but know this I felt
very much
another sensation I had is uh just keep
treading water that I was no had no
control over my life right gonna live or
die but it wasn't chaotic because it
Taiwan really well organized of British
and Americans are well organized people
trying to rescue me very well organized
sat I could hear it sat at the drones
flying over and those were probably
filming
so it's not chaos but there was these
you realize you're on a stage and it's a
shadowy world of dark
uh actors and you don't know what's
happening
uh you know you're you're in a spy
versus spice strategic I and you know
I'm in the most the tribalist which had
at that point the most what's called
high value targets or Taliban Al-Qaeda
Terrace so there'll be U.S satellites
and drones looking
and they would I was aware well they if
if they thought I was in the same house
as Osama Bin Laden they wouldn't rescue
me they'd [ __ ] yeah hit me as well
Pakistan who's denying so you're you're
suddenly in a very complicated that was
the backdrop to my kidnap so I didn't
feel it was chaotic I just felt oh my
God it's just too many
things happening so many elements so
many elements so I know that
um the circumstances regarding your
release are quite complex and a am I
right in thinking they can't fully be
discussed
well I don't know it's mainly because
I'm like I said I was kept in the I
didn't know what's happening yeah so I
know negotiations go on uh between
so channel four uh hired a private
company and and actually actually some
of my friends local journalists my
fixers is lots of people
and uh involved in uh negotiations
but you don't know who's negotiating I
didn't know the direct things
um what I do know there wasn't an an uh
because the title I know the Taliban
told me they were ordered to just
uh negotiate quickly because I was an
embarrassment to Pakistan being there
you know it was pretty they were why it
was going to bring too much attention to
the terrorist training camps
so it was they were just told get it get
it I'm done with but yeah I I was never
told by Channel 4 how things were done
I've read about it in the paper
but you can you talk us through the
release how did you know you were about
to be released and what and what what
happened yeah
well again I I think last time I was
here didn't I I there was this hearing
it was again that Charming commander and
I I called him Mr C like he had to charm
of the devil uh he enters
after four months well actually I can
one thing I know I didn't tell before
it's a rather dark
Macabre story but Muller medicated who
pulled a knife and said I just want to
show you that was the beginning of
making up he disappeared I thought he'd
been dragged off to his dad yes well he
reappears right at the end when I'm told
you're going to be released I'm like wow
you seem to recovered
and
something remarkable happened which you
know so despite all my saying fairly
which is I firmly believe most people
around the world are completely normal
and people join these groups for
understandable reasons there aren't
extremes like baseball Muller medicated
is the exception that proves the rule
so when he knows I'm going to release he
says
he says can I ask you a question
and I've been interrogated at gunpoint
for three months
and I'm now looking like Robinson Crusoe
and and I'm like yeah of course you can
ask me a question like we haven't asked
before you just he said no no but it's
it's slightly delicate uh slightly of an
offensive nature you might take offense
and I started laughing thinking he's
being really polite but
I'm thinking we didn't he wasn't so
polite when he abducted kidnapped me and
so I'm like no please whatever you want
and what was it funny about this is this
is clearly what the Taliban wanted to
know about because all the guards put
their gun down they all sat on my feet
I'm sitting on some little
chair
and the Muller medicated all the Taliban
put their weapons down and they're
looking up because this is the real
question they didn't want to know about
what forces Americans had of British
they wanted to know this and I said
please whatever you want God is you sure
you won't take offense someone no he
said okay is it true
uh women in the West
are free to marry animals
oh my God and I'm sitting there
and I look like and then he pauses he
says not just any animal but really
small animals as well so I like now this
is where I got the debtors I know I'm
about to be released and this guy
got to be very careful they don't like
you laugh but I suddenly get the giggles
thinking it's like that friend in class
and you know that she says the next
person who laughs in detention I'm
thinking if I laugh I'm getting executed
but I suddenly get this giggle thinking
the eye the idea that you could believe
women are free to marry animals but you
can't quite believe even small animals I
want to say yeah you know I know lots of
women who've married a rhinoceros have
elephant but we draw the line at little
things there we're not that uh but I was
trying to stay for my I said no no sorry
no I'm not sure to my life no I why why
are you asking he said well
and it was so exact he said well we read
an article and all the Taliban were like
nodding it all said read the same story
about a woman in Holland who married a
frog
can you know I'm looking at my fixer and
I say is this [ __ ] Muller mad
and he says no I've heard the same story
I'm like oh my God you're all mad
so I went no I don't know I don't think
it's legal to marry frogs in Holland uh
where do you really he said but I read
this heart and slowly it's Dawning me so
there was even a photograph
this blonde Dutch woman
with a frog what the frog prince and I
said was there something odd about that
frog was it wearing a crown and he went
yeah like I'd read the same article and
then I realized they've confused
the Frog Prince fairy tale with reality
now what's disturbing about that is this
mother was in charge of hundreds of
Taliban fires so no doubt he's telling
his man look the Americas will come here
to invade our country rape our women and
they [ __ ] frogs you know
I uh and I'm like oh my God this is it's
not about oil or Guantanamo Bay they
think we're having sex with frogs
I when I got back to England
this is how it works the irony is in the
1950s America to to help Afghans have
translated to help them the children
read to translate to the Frog Prince
fairy tale into Pash Doom so it's been
given out to every Afghan child
to help the west of 50 years later it's
been Twisted back by the Taliban to use
against us I know that was before that's
when I thought that's Muller because
thank God they didn't get Goldilocks and
the Three Bears that would have been
running a lot of fairy tales
I mean uh okay grandmother what great
big teeth you got yeah
Osama what no but the the command that
was just before so I'm reeling from oh
my God it's so this is what we're
fighting but at this point this actually
can you tell us the trail thing again
because I think it's yeah I think you
did tell it but it's a nice so that was
that was it was like full circle so you
know I'd met the mother he drove me and
he turns up just before my day in court
everything happened inside my cell I
never had to go anywhere because the
world came to me so I meet them and I'm
like tell them about frogs
then the the Taliban commander and he
sort of floats into the room in his long
clothes and he takes himself very
seriously he sits
and asked me to sit opposite him so I am
like in on the dock in court
and at this stage
and I know they've come to announce that
because he had said we're going to
investigate you and he was very clear
when he left he said look don't worry
about it
you'll either both die or they live it's
not going to be like those other cases
where we let the foreign live so I know
he's coming
and a few weeks before I felt like we
were going to be released and and I for
the first time let the all my I'd kept
my emotions locked down I let my
emotions out but oh my God I'm going to
see Lukey and Gabriel my life's gonna
start again and then when we weren't
released you crash like and so hope is a
really good so I'm sitting there not
wanting to Hope
that I might be freed
but also you know I I was completely not
worried about being shot or killed you
know I'd had that conversation with them
I'd asked do you mind shooting me
because I got a problem having my head
cut they said look don't worry
you know because I I appointed the owner
of the house if we if it comes to my
death I want you to shoot me because you
we've got on and he cried with that God
so now I'm in the seed has to be shot in
the back of the head yeah because I
rather English I said uh I said I've got
a slight problem over my throat cut yeah
it's like
uh but what happened was
I said uh and do and I thought well if
you're going to be shot and it's nice if
someone you like so I when I appointed
him he cried
because he was rather touched that I
pointed but so that had already been got
we don't dealt with that so I'm now with
the Taliban judge and he literally
pulls out the
rather like when they accuse me
initially they read out this scroll it's
like on the scroll you're here by charge
now he's got this scroll and I'm sitting
there waiting my fate life or death and
I'm sticking with the fixer
and
he says
by order a fish of the Taliban Amir
you're hereby found
innocent
and he looks at me and he lets that
you know so I don't know
you know it's like it's like that movie
it's like good day you know like you got
off
and and then he draws breath
but the shura which is the ruling
governing Council the ruling governing
Council the sure of the Taliban sure
voted to kill you
to stop other journalists trying to do
the same thing and I'm like oh
so I'm like Innocent but they're going
to kill me
and that's when I the emotions now are
ah [ __ ] I'm gonna be killed I'm not
gonna see the kids
and just as I'm the emotion's about to
burst out he then
but don't worry about that because me
and the Amir out you know we we vetoed
the rest assurer and we we voted to let
you live oh my God so I just I mean oh
so I'd literally mean you're innocent
we're gonna kill you don't worry
we so I'm sitting there and I'm just
a like a pool of a mess on the carpet
and then he says to my fixer
okay the sure the governing council at
the time I'd found you guilty
but we're going to let you live
and we didn't believe it but but so they
they separate us
uh and that's when uh
I'm putting a burka
and giving some girls ladies shoes which
didn't fit and I'm trying to I'm looking
out the Burke and you can't see anything
and it's like it's filtering you're sort
of squinting about wow not only are they
this they can't see the world so you're
in prison you can't even see output of
these things
I thought it's ironic that that there I
am being released and I first taste of
what it must be like to be a woman in
prison dude
and that's when the the Taliban try so
I'm not really aware of what the
negotiations are but there's suddenly
there's a phone call I'm in a safe house
and it was full of wounded Taliban and
slightly deranged people who had severe
mental health issues and it was like a
Macabre final moment I know I was Miss
it was so bad I was missing the idyllic
place
because they were like people pouring me
like oh no yeah it was really a so
strange place and it was just some
people who had some who've been wounded
in the head or something
that's when the Taliban are calling
whoever might negotiating for me and
saying we've got the package
and that's when I say
because I vowed to my fixer not to leave
without him because we didn't want to be
like that Italian yeah this he was the
man I'd mentioned before we're having
those great adventures to fix her
he been kidnapped and telling the
Italians paid for that guy's release and
poor Afghan figure gets killed right and
I vowed We're Not Gonna I promise you so
when I'm here in the Taliban talking
about we've just got one package to
deliver I'm like no no and I I turned to
God and uh you know pray
please give me the strength uh uh
because I knew I had about 10 seconds
before I was going to say I'm I'm good
let's go it's like every single in my
body wanted to be released see my
children but I say I'm not leaving
without a fixer so and a guy looked to
me he's like
and at that point everything's like
clockwork and it's very dangerous
they've clearly got man and a alley over
the car yeah someone on a phone
whatever's happening in the hostage
release situation
so he didn't he was like oh so he just
gets another fence is Right release the
other package
so that's for now me and the fixer will
release at the same time God and uh this
lovely American picked us up and I was
crying but
at that point you were crying
you said you were crying yeah first
thing I couldn't stop loving because now
I I've spent three and a half months of
a lot blocking down the battling down
your hatches whether I mean the minute
this lovely American voice says welcome
home sir and has me a donut and a coffee
I started crying because you just feel
like
but where it was
uh
uh uh and again from my experience in
war zones you don't relax until you're
really you know but it was when I got to
Heathrow
and you know I the hardest point I don't
think I've talked about this before but
the longest day when you talk about
every uh
a minute can be a lifetime
actually you know I'd refuse to give the
names for my children but what Gabriel
but
the worst point was was Gable turned
four when I was in captivity now I as I
was telling you earlier you feel so
connected to your loved ones and I'm
escaping for myself
that day is the longest day of my life
because I in my head and I know the time
in London I see him wake up this little
three-year-old has just turned four
not knowing why Daddy's away because her
mum was protecting but they sent
something and he I could see him wake up
full of excitement running into Mommy's
bedroom opening presents looking for
where Daddy's is and whenever I was away
I would still send presents with big
boxes from house and ribbons and not
seeing Daddy and then at lunch time
thinking Daddy's going to come in and
then and I had this Dreadful
I I mean it almost killed me
is that his last thoughts is he's on his
bunk bed and I could see him liners well
maybe Daddy doesn't love me
uh so when I come back from released
and I'm at Heathrow four months later
and the doors open there's little
Gabriel on his scooter he rushes
straight we said Daddy Daddy I'm four
and I'm like I know you'll find out and
I'm I cried and I thought I'm hugging
him like I know your thought I'm sorry I
didn't call
and that's when uh it'll you know relax
it was all you know I was over and done
with
yeah it's the first time during a
telling of that story that you look like
you've actually been hit with a bit of
emotion as well yeah because it's uh
uh you know kids because I thought it
was the it's there there's the yeah I
mean I don't know
to bring it up again but it is the uh
well so so when you go through a very
bristle experience it's it's uh it never
quite Fades into the past tense like any
trauma
so it actually uh less so now but I
years after my kiddo I could close my
eyes and be back living that moment with
a gun to my head or a knife
and feeling people's pain your love on
suffering so it never quite Fades and
it's forever more in a present tense
it's interesting you say that because
the final question I was going to ask
you
um which has sort of been answered a bit
but what's interesting to me is you've
got undergone a situation that was like
deeply traumatic to people who aren't
used to it you were a little bit more
experienced in that world but not to the
extent of the period you went through
but it doesn't feel externally like you
you wear it on you very much like it I
would say that we I've met quite a lot
of people who have very who've gone
through similar traumatic experiences
and it's quite clear to see the impact
it's having but you seem quite a upbeat
person even in the discussion of it like
there's a few bits where you were
talking about
quite Bleak stuff and you sort of almost
smiled a bit and I got drawn into
laughing at it because it's like I know
it's quite and some people find that uh
disconcerting or like why is he laughing
about death
uh and I didn't feel that I just felt
you come across as somebody who's well
it's the unbearable lightness of being
sure it is
uh
is you the the the well the the are you
it's I you don't get over a trauma
and you don't uh uh you you live with it
and actually
uh I found it so it's a it's not
unpleasant to people my phone find oh
that I can be looking like it's so
lovely on a beach you know enjoying some
lovely food with friends you know
because I could have been it you know in
my head you know I've just spent two I
had quite a few friends colleagues
kidnapped beheaded by ISIS
I can think of them whilst enjoying
myself because they are
that shadow shines I think it's the uh
when you have that shadow of suffering
and death and Trauma it casts
a brilliant light on on life it's like a
painting without the Shadows it's not
going to be as beautiful it was just
Bland photograph
and so I don't regret anything that
happened to me it there's a lot of uh
stuff you carry with you but it's like
Scrooge you know the Christmas carol
he must have been pretty terrifying
having those ghosts at the bottom
rattling in the story of the Ghost of
Christmas Past but he wakes up Christmas
day full of life's job with this added
thing which only suffering and fear and
Trauma
and what I mean by that is
uh that was the first time in my life I
just had a taste of what millions of
people in this world are living through
every day
and I heard on the radio when I was
captured about this woman in Somalia who
was having
every day her husband had to cross three
roadblocks to get bread
and she always worried he wouldn't come
back and then she's telling the story to
the BBC guy but of course he gets shot
and she's crying and I cry this is that
I'm weeping because For the first time
in her life I know what it's like to
live in fear
and I could feel her suffering as though
it was my owner and and that was an
amazing privilege that
we in the west somehow turn our backs on
the world suffering or suffering within
our own countries
to make our lives easier but in fact you
can't really turn your backs on the
world's suffering and it eats awareness
so to to open up to other people's
suffering and plight through just having
tasted myself
well that's it carries some pain and
baggage but it's it's
um I'm smiling because it's you realize
how wonderful the world is and how good
life is you know
well look Sean it's been an absolutely
massive pleasure to meet you again it's
fascinating insight into your post group
you can I've seen that that the meaning
of life and I thought I'm gonna come
back I'll be across between Jesus Christ
Mother Teresa I'm going to give all my
love a week later I'm in a bar in London
drinking a strawberry daiquiri doing a
line of coke thinking my life would be
better with a Mercedes
the end
[Laughter]
[Music]
so that was Sean Langdon a documentary
maker and journalist but who is well
known for being kidnapped and held
hostage by the Taliban I'm joined now by
the episodes director Josh and off
camera the producer Danny uh Josh what
were your thoughts
really liked him I really like nice way
about him so chatty so chatty and funny
and self-deprecating in his humor
um and yeah I mean it's like
for me kind of like starting out in
journalism as well that was kind of like
what I thought I was going to do did a
bit of it and realized God no so you're
here like yeah yeah literally yeah I'm
much happier safer um but yeah so for me
like I'm just like drawn to these
stories and Iraq Afghanistan war and
someone that goes there and is
gone to make documents in Sullivan and
then his uh kidnapping story is just so
you know it's so incredible given
everything we know about it and that
like what goes on and then the little
intricacies like him getting fried eggs
for breakfast because they asked for it
well the bit about the question about
whether Western women are allowed to
marry frogs
yeah I mean it just shows what like the
propaganda on both sides but I mean
that's
it's quite an extreme form of it isn't
it yeah
um exactly it's just such a bunker story
and the then the motivation of why I do
it why go back uh the feeling had just
before I you hit I find you hear that a
lot that before the trip you get
kidnapped in everyone goes I had a funny
feeling about it but I don't actually
think that's true I just think that
that's hindsight must play with it
because before every trip before to
somewhere dangerous you're going to be a
bit worried and then when it all goes
wrong you're like oh I saw that coming
yeah I I thought he was great I really
enjoyed talking to him a fascinating
story great way of telling it at the bit
I was trying to get into that I don't
think I really did in a satisfactory way
was just why do you do it because as a
young man trying to prove himself
setting out into that world I can
completely understand that going I'll go
to the places no one else will go to and
I'll do the things no one else will but
once he had his kids and you know it was
clear that they're massively important
to him you know the only part in the
piece where he really showed some really
deep emotion was talking about his
children I'm surprised that he he he
still keeps going back although I did
think by the end he gave a very
articulate and interesting answer about
the fact that you can only really
appreciate
the joy in the world when you've seen
the true darkness of it
how did we think that I was going to act
through that when there was a fact about
westerners marrying for us
yeah yeah all I did was nod and smile
obviously here going what the [ __ ] is
that a voice in the last meeting okay so
uh would you would you've ever gone then
like even when you were younger can you
imagine going to a war zone no
definitely not like I am very
risk-averse as a person and something
like that the to do it for the sake of a
job even if I really believed I was
uncovering something really important it
just wouldn't have been the payoff
wouldn't have been worth the risk for me
what about you I mean journalism I would
never I was more into football than War
um I couldn't imagine going to somewhere
where you'd be your life would be in
danger like it it feels so strange to
run toward trouble and he that's what he
does I like his first job DJ
correspondence
so charge expenses and he was like yeah
I don't I get that not feeling the
meaning but it's a no choice to go from
that to chasing probably you know less
money
yeah I mean for me it was the takeaway
was just how to try and appreciate in
terms of how big the world is how many
people are in it how few people have the
daily life that we have in terms of when
he was talking about being with his
fixer who is a native to that area and
him saying oh I think it'll be okay in
the fix to go no no we're dead it was
just kind of like for people in that
life he just the fixing you that the
chances were they were gonna die because
the price of Life there is so low and he
thought it was so high and he thought it
was so hard but he was in the wrong
place and it's just trying not to take
things for granted I suppose we managed
to interrupt the drug Supply in
Northampton for a full two hours so
seven months of work nine months 96
people arrested
being constantly in fear of my life
being assaulted you know I was at one
point I was stripped naked